[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend den Sport in der Sendung den
hat heute Norbert König guten Abend dann
verschaffen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam
einen
Überblick kein Rotstift beim Klima
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck bekräftigt
vor den energieministern der Länder dass
die Haushaltskrise keine geplanten
Projekte ausbremsen
dürfe neue Hoffnung für die gaz Geiseln
die Waffenruhe wird verlängert
Bundespräsident Steinmeier verspricht in
einem israelischen kibutz Hilfe beim
Wiederaufbau und alle Jahre wieder die
ersten großflächigen Schneefälle der
Saison überraschen viele und begeistern
andere nach dem 60 Milliarden Urteil hat
die Bundesregierung heute den
Nachtragshaushalt 2023 verabschiedet und
will dafür wieder die Schuldenbremse
aussetzen morgen äußert sich dazu ganz
offiziell auch der Kanzler schon heute
traf sich Wirtschaftsminister habbeck
mit seinen Länderkollegen und da ging es
vor allem um den klimagerechten Umbau
der Wirtschaft und mögliche
Einsparpotenziale das Ergebnis lässt
sich kurz zusammenfassen sparen ja aber
nicht bei uns was wiederum die
aufgeregte Debatte über den Umgang mit
der Schuldenbremse weit anfeuern dürfte
dazu Klaus brotbeck
habbeck kämpft um Geld und quer durch
alle politischen Lager scheinen die
Wirtschafts und Energieminister aus den
Ländern dabei trotz des Urteils des
Verfassungsgerichtes wollen sie an allen
Projekten des Klima und
transformationsfond festhalten die
Projekte mit die mit dem Klima und
transformationsfond sich verbinden sie
betreffen den wirtschaftlichen Kern
Deutschlands die Konjunkturdaten sind
denke ich inzwischen in der
Öffentlichkeit bekannt alleine durch den
Wegfall der 60 Milliarden im KTF
erwarten wir einen Verlust an Wachstum
im nächsten Jahr von einem guten halben
Prozentpunkt es sind keine nice to have
Projekte sondern es sind unverzichtbare
Projekte die hier in den Ländern in
Kofinanzierung mit dem Bund in vielen
Fällen auf den Weg gebracht worden sind
immer stärker Gerät deswegen die
Schuldenbremse unter Druck sie müsse
reformiert werden in der Ampel hält die
FDP aber weiter dagegen Bund und Länder
die haben weniger ein Einnahmeproblem
sie haben vor allen Dingen ein
ausgabeproblem und an der Stelle ist
eben auch Sparen angesagt so wie es
jeder von zu Hause kennt wenn das Geld
knapper wird dann muss man zuallererst
sparen und sich nicht über zusätzliche
Einnahmen Gedanken machen sondern sparen
ist das Gebot der Stunde auch die Union
will die Schuldenbremse weder
reformieren noch abschaffen sie fordert
von der Koalition eine grundlegende
Wende ihrer
Haushaltspolitik so jedenfalls wie sie
in den letzten zwei Jahren operiert
haben geht es in den zu end gehehenden
Monaten vielleicht zwei Jahren dieser
Wahlperiode nicht weiter und insofern
erwarte ich morgen eine zweite
Zeitenwende Rede den Druck rauszunehmen
die Debatte zu beruhigen das wird Olaf
Scholz morgen versuchen wie auch immer
leicht wird es
nicht jetzt nach Berlin zu shakuntala
benerg shakunala Wirtschaftsminister und
Länderkollegen haben Pflöcke
eingeschlagen sehen keine
Einsparpotenziale was bedeutet das für
die aktuelle schuldendiskussion ja das
zeigt vor allem wie hart der Kampf ums
Geld jetzt hinter den Kulissen schon
tobt die Länder haben offensichtlich
große Sorge davor dass ihnen da
Milliarden Fördergelder vom Bund
verloren gehen vor allem für sogenannte
Zukunftsprojekte an denen wiederum in
vielen Regionen vor allem
strukturschwachenregionen alte und neue
Industriearbeitsplätze hängen und darauf
möchte man natürlich nicht verzichten
das ist also heute ein Signal gewesen
dass dass man da drum kämpfen möchte
soweit das geht und es zeigt auch eine
zweite Sache nämlich dass
Friedrich märz mit seiner ganz harten
Haltung zur Schuldenbremse nicht bei
allen in der Union volle Rückendeckung
hat aus mehreren Bundesländern
namentlich schleswig- Holstein Berlin
Sachsen und SachsenAnhalt kamen schon
Töne von den CDU Ministerpräsidenten die
durchscheinen lassen dass man da
flexibler ist und dass man mindestens
Spielräume sieht also
viel viel wird gerungen um die Frage
woher soll das Geld für in Zukunft
kommen für Investitionen und das Ganze
ist natürlich auch ein Signal vor dem
morgigen Auftritt von Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz im Bundestag der dann erst einmal
erklären soll wo es jetzt lang gehen
soll und woher er das Geld nehmen möchte
danke für die Einschätzung nach Berlin
schakunteller ja der vom haushaltsurteil
Betroffene
klimatransformationsfond KTF welche
Projekte sollen eigentlich aus ihm
finanziert werden Beispiele haben wir
online aufgelistet jederzeit nachzulesen
in unserer ZDF heute
App durch das Haushaltsloch könnte auch
Geld für ein anderes ehrgeiziges Projekt
fehlen die klimafreundliche
Verkehrswende Olaf Scholz lut heute zum
autogipfel ins Kanzleramt mit
Branchenvertretern Wissenschaft und
Umweltverbänden wurde diskutiert wie die
Elektromobilität zügig ausgebaut werden
kann das Ziel bis 2030 will die
Regierung 15 Millionen vollelektrische
Autos auf Deutschlands Straßen bringen
noch klafft aber eine riesige Lücke denn
zum sticht 1 Oktober waren gerade einmal
1,3 Millionen E-Autos
registriert ja wir wollen Nachfragen bei
Frank betmann in Frankfurt an der Börse
Frank eine Riesenlücke bei der
Elektromobilität wer hat das zu
verantworten Politik oder doch eher die
Industrie da schobt man sich bisher den
sprichwörtlich schwarzen Peter gerne
gegenseitig zu heute vom autogipfel nun
das ganz klare Signal wir schaffen das
nur zusammen jeder sprach heute von
großer Einigkeit Einigkeit darin dass
E-Autos billiger werden müssen der ADAC
hatte erst jüngst bemängelt dass es
überhaupt nur drei Modelle gebe die
derzeit laut Liste weniger als 30 000 €
Kosten würden nun ist es aber so je
billiger ein Auto werden muss desto
schwieriger ist es im Fahrzeugbau die
Kosten zu verstecken insbesondere ein
Problem für die deutschen Autobauer da
passt die Aussage von Volkswagen
Markenchef Schäfer ins Bild der offen
zugibt wir sind mit der Marke VW nicht
mehr wettbewerbsfähig milliarden müssen
eingespart Personal soll abgebaut werden
der Druck ist groß auch bei anderen
Autobauern die heute mit am Tisch saßen
eine Antwort vermutlich die wichtigste
blieb der Gipfel im übrigen schuldig
nämlich ob die Bundesregierung ihre
förder zu sagen für die Autobranche wird
aufrechterhalten können das ist derzeit
völlig offen vielen Dank nach Frankfurt
Frank wetmann
ja morgen früh 7 Uhr unserer Zeit sollte
die viertägige Feuerpause zwischen
Israel und der radikal islamischen Hamas
enden beide Seiten haben sich aber jetzt
darauf verständigt das Abkommen um
weitere zwei Tage zu verlängern für
heute wird erwartet dass wieder 11
israelische Geiseln und über 30
palästinensische Häftlinge freigelassen
werden l
walpot Freude gestern im kibut quaasa
sie feiern die Rückkehr von Geiseln aus
ihrer Gemeinde darunter die vierjährige
usstaatsbürgerin afigel edan ihr
Großvater einer der ersten der sie
sehenfte
es war unglaublich ich konnte es nicht
fassen ich bin einfach nur erleichtert
aber es gibt andere die noch nicht
zurückgekehrt sind ich will dass auch
sie
heimkommen 51 Tage war die kleine avigil
in den Händen von hamasterroristen die
beim Überfall am 7 Oktober erst ihre
Mutter dann ihren Vater erschossen der
sich schützend über sie legte dann wurde
avigil nach Gaza verschleppt wie viele
andere auch mehr als 180 Geiseln sind
noch in der Hand der Hammers und doch
heute warten die israelischen Familien
wieder auf die gute
Nachricht die Feuerpause sollte
ausgeweitet werden wir wollen dass alle
nach Hause kommen was auch immer dafür
verlangt
wird nach einigen Verzögerungen hieß es
am Abend weitere
Geiseln neun Kinder und zwei Frauen
werden heute freigelassen und noch eine
gute Nachricht meldeten die Vermittler
aus Qatar die Feuerpause wird um zwei
Tage verlängert Zeit um mehr Geiseln
freizulassen Zeit auch um mehr hilfs
Lieferungen für die Zivilbevölkerung in
den Gazastreifen zu bringen in hanunis
nutzten tausende die Gelegenheit um
Treibstoff kochgas und Lebensmittel zu
besorgen die Warteschlangen sind
lang wir können nur noch einmal am Tag
teetinken weil kein Gas da ist die
Kinder gehen hungrig zu Bett es gibt
kaum Brot vorerst hält die Feuerpause
mit ihr auch die Hoffnung auf beiden
Seiten Solidarität mit den Opfern ät mit
dem ganzen Land Bundespräsident
steinmeierer hat heute erneut betont wie
fest Deutschland an der Seite Israels
steht er besuchte den kibutz Beeri in
der Nähe des Gazastreifens am 7 Oktober
waren mordende hamaserroristen durch die
Siedlung gezogen um zumindest die
äußeren Wunden zu lindern versprach
steinmeierer beim Wiederaufbau zu helfen
Patrizia wiedermeierer
berichtet es ist nicht mehr viel übrig
von der idille vergangener Zeiten hier
im kibut nah der Grenze zu Gaza die
Zerstörung unfassbar 130 Menschen wurden
ermordet rund 50 als Geiseln genommen
junge israelische Soldatinnen waren hier
einen Tag nach dem Massaker durch die
Hamas das waren Szenen aus einem
Albtraum diese Zerstörung überall
Leichen der Geruch
furchtbar unter den Opfern auch Vivian
Silv eine 74-jährige
Friedensaktivistin sie fuhr einmal die
Woche nach Gaza kranke Frauen und Kinder
in israelische Krankenhäuser zu bringen
sie wurde umgebracht und wir brauchten
einen Monat um Sie zu identifizieren es
war nichts mehr von ihr übrig
Bundespräsident Steinmeier kommt
zusammen mit dem israelischen
Präsidenten beide geschockt versuchen
sie trotzdem Zuversicht zu verbreiten
Herzog verspricht alles wieder
aufzubauen Deutschland will 7 Millionen
geben für beri beri und die vielen
anderen kiboim haben es verdient dass
sie nicht nur Teil der israelischen
Geschichte sind
sondern vor allen Dingen auch Teil der
Zukunft Israels sein werden die die den
7 Oktober hier überlebt haben wollen
wiederkommen trotz
allem das ist doch meine Heimat ich bin
hier
aufgewachsen israel hat die
Verpflichtung hier in dieser Region für
Sicherheit zu sorgen und nicht nur
Israel nein die ganze Welt so ihre
botschaftcken wir Polen
Regierungsbildung dort zur Erinnerung
die nationalkonservative peace des
bisherigen Regierungschefs moravki hat
nach der Wahl keine Mehrheit im
Parlament und auch keine
Koalitionspartner trotzdem hat moravetki
heute ein neues Kabinett vorgestellt wie
das alles zusammenpasst erklärt uns
jetzt Natalie
Steger es ist ein taktisches Manöver was
die Nationalkonservativen Polens da
abhalten um den Machtwechsel zu
verzögern präsidentuda ein
vor erst Ministerpräsident mor plus
Kabinett ich vertraue darauf dass Sie
alle Herausforderungen schaffen werden
der Ministerpräsident verhandelt derzeit
über die Unterstützung für dieses
Kabinett die Verhandlungen allerdings
erfolglos im neuen Parlament ist die
peace zwar die stärkste Kraft hat aber
die absolute Mehrheit verloren die hat
eine proeuropäische Koalition unter der
Führung von Donald Tusk die noch ST eng
zusammen hat bereits einen
Koalitionsvertrag ist bereit zum
Regieren wir beobachten eine Mission die
keine ist sondern ein Versuch Geld zu
verdienen und etwas Zeit zu
gewinnen die peace schöpft alle Fristen
aus die neuen kurzzeitminister werden
Abfindungen erhalten viele weitere der
eigenen Leute können noch schnell mit
lukrativen Posten versorgt werden in
spätestens Wochen
mussass die Vertrauensfrage stellen und
wird verlieren dann schlägt die Stunde
von Donald Tusk der dann wohl Mitte
Dezember der neue Ministerpräsident
Polens wird die ur tickt Firmen LKW
spezialisiert auf Aktenvernichtung
wurden vor Ministerien gesichtet für die
Opposition ist klar wofür die peace die
Zeit braucht bis Z Machtwechsel
belastendes Material
entsorgen die Büros werden Lehrer die
Arztpraxen voller in Deutschland mehren
sich die Krankheitsfälle die großen
Krankenkassen melden einen Rekordstand
das Robert Koch Institut verzeichnet in
den vergangenen Wochen einen Anstieg von
Fällen mit Grippe ähnlichen Symptomen
zuletzt mit leichtem Rückgang aber
bleibt bei recht hohem Niveau auch die
Zahl der akuten Atemwegserkrankungen
nimmt zu in beide Kurven flossen
coronaerkrankungen mit ein Susanne
Freitag
carteron seit Wochen ist Michael
offen Mund tief ein und ausatmen in
seiner Hausarztpraxis vor allem
Patienten mit Infekten der atemwiege
aber auch wieder rund 20 covidfälle
täglich die Hausärzte kämpfen mit einer
massiven
Infektionswelle im Umlauf sind im
Wesentlichen typische virale Infektionen
ausgelöst durch bestimmte Viren die
Halsschmerzen machen Kopfschmerzen
machen sehr starkes Krankheitsgefühl
auslösen die Patienten haben Fieber und
manchmal werden die diese Dinge dann
nach einigen Tagen Fieber von heftigem
Husten oder auch Entzündung der Nasen
Nebenhöhlen abgelöst die Bedingungen für
Viren aller Art sind nach der
covidpandemie besonders
günstig das Hauptproblem ist dass unser
Immunsystem in den letzten Jahren in
denen wir uns vor Corona geschützt haben
massiv wenig Reize gehabt hat und eine
na Schwäche nicht aber eine
immundelle entwickelt hat und diese
immundelle sorgt jetzt dafür dass so
viele Menschen auf einmal krank geworden
sind covid ist inzwischen ein Virus
unter vielen die Inzidenzen steigen
massiv besondere Schutzmaßnahmen aber
gibt es nicht wir wissen heute die
wichtigste Maßnahme ist eigentlich der
mundnasenschutz der hilft effektiv plus
Impfung aber tatsächlich ist unsere
herdenimmunität praktisch die Immunität
in unserer gesamten Bevölkerung so groß
dass ich mir derzeit eben keine großen
Sorgen ma die Ständige Impfkommission
empfiehlt älteren Menschen und
Risikogruppen eine boost Impfung und den
Grippeschutz denn da droht die große
Welle am Jahresende gute besser schwere
Stürme haben die ukrainische
Schwarzmeerküste die Krim und Orte im
Süden Russlands getroffen besonders die
Region um soi das Meer peitschte die
Wellen Meter hoch mindestens zwei
Menschen starben der Wind hatte
Geschwindigkeiten von mehr als 140 km
die Stunde Verkehrschaos auch in der
Ukraine in Odessa knickte der Sturm den
100 cm 110 m hohen Schornstein eines
Heizkraftwerks um 150.000 Menschen
wurden vom Stromnetz
abgeschnitten sie kriegen das mit
Deutschland zieht sich gerade neu an
überwiegend in Weiß Schnee es gibt jede
Menge Schnee der Winter ist da und der
wird in weiten Teilen des Landes für ein
paar Tage anhalten Grund dafür ein
umfangreiches tief der sich nur langsam
von Nordwesten nach Südosten Verlag und
im Gepäck hat viel Feuchtigkeit Sandra
teis fasst diesen wettertag heute
zusammen es ist jedes Jahr dasselbe die
weiße Pracht wie hier im Erzgebirge
sorgt auf den Straßen für winterliches
Chaos viele Orts kommt es zu Unfällen
auf der B49 in der Nähe von kolenz
verliert eine Frau die Kontrolle über
ihr Auto und kracht in den Gegenverkehr
die 54jährige stirbt noch an der
Unfallstelle der Fahrer des
entgegenkommenden fahrze
wer vor allem die Lastwagenfahrer
kämpfen mit dem Schnee auf der A1 bei
querschied im Saarland blockierte ein
LKW die Ausfahrt passiert war was auf
Schnee so oft geschieht wer einmal steht
kriegt die Karre nicht mehr ins Rollen
die PKW sind immer langsamer geworden
und einer ist immer kurz steh geblieben
war der Schwung weg und anfah konnte ich
Seen ich zur Fahrbahn ST auf der B
inbach rutscht ein LKW Graben der Fahrer
wird verletzt kann sich aber selbst aus
der Kabine retten in den kommenden
Stunden soll es vieler Orts weiter
schneien wer kann sollte das Auto stehen
lassen und den Schnee genießen Sowi hier
in reitem
winkelal muss ich sagen wir haben jetzt
übernach noch mit 10 cm Schnee kriegt
gerade für die Korne ist es natürlich
ideal und für eine Schneeballschlacht
sollen auch morgen genug Flocken vom
Himmel
kommen t sehr hübsch hier zum Sport und
Norbert König der BVB der muss morgen
nicht im Schnee spielen ne nee für
Mailand sind 10° angesagt plus natürlich
Edin tersit BVB fährt in dieser Saison
also nicht Schlitten sondern so ein
bisschen Achterbahn den höchsten Punkt
will Dortmund in der Champions League
aber nicht verlassen also die
Tabellenführung verteidigen beim AC
Mailand ein Team der
Stimmungsschwankungen das ist die
Borussia in dieser Saison von deprimiert
bis elektrisiert in wenigen Minuten im
Ligaspiel gegen mönchenggladbach 30
Minuten lang wie ein Abstiegskandidat
aus einem frustrierenden 0 Z2 dann noch
ein 4 Z2 gemacht das ist das andere
Gesicht des BVB der sich in der
vielleicht stärksten Champions League
Gruppe durch zwei Siege gegen Newcastle
an die Spitze gesetzt hat das
Achtelfinale ist greifbar gegen den
morgigen Gegner AC Mailand fehlte schon
im Hinspiel nicht viel zum Sieg wir
haben uns das harte erarbeitet gerade
auch mit den beiden Siegen gegen
Newcastle und das wollen wir uns jetzt
nicht mehr nehmen lassen nach dem
Erkrankten süle droht nun auchch
Schlotterbeck in der Abwehr auszufallen
Trainer tersic hofft dass sein Team
trotzdem das erfolgreiche Champions
League Gesicht
zeigt in der Fußballbundesliga bleiben
Heidenheims Trainer Schmidt und Bochums
Coach Lech nach dem 0:0 Tabellennachbarn
auf Platz 13 und 14 dort hätte auch Jan
siet stehen können mit Mainz 05 die
Mainzer gingen in Hoffenheim durch
Richter kurz vor der Pause mit 1:0 in
Führung kurz nach dem Wechsel besorgte
go für die TSG den ein zu ein Endstand
torhter Baumann hielt später den
schwachgeschossenen Meter des Mainzers
barkock eine von zahlreichen vergebenen
Chancen der Gäste alle Tore alle
Höhepunkte des Z Spieltags finden Sie
auch unter
zdfheute.de und in der ZDF heute App
Lena D verpasst zum ersten Mal das
Podium im dritten Weltcup slalon dieser
Saison nach Platz 2 und 3 dieses Mal
Rang 4 in
killington h fehlen zum Sprung aufs
stockal Superstar Mikaela schifffrin
feiert auf ihrer Heimstrecke im
usbundesstaat Vermont ihren 90
Weltcupsieg zweite wird Petra willova
Slowakei dritte die Schweizerin Wendy
Holdener
90 weltcupsiegel mit noch 28 Jahren also
das wird garantiert noch dreistellig
danke dir Norbert jetzt noch eine
ziemlich spektakulre Geburt nach 460
Tagen Schwangerschaft die Tierschützer
ganz besonders freut ein Sumatra
nasornbaby hat in Indonesien das Licht
der Welt erblickt 25 kg schwer und eine
absolute Seltenheit denn die Art ist vom
Aussterben bedroht weltweit schätzt man
den Bestand auf höchstens 80 Exemplare
sehr
süß noch mal zum Winterwetter da warnt
der Deutsche Wetterdienst aktuell vor
starkem Schneefall in Teilen von Hessen
und Rheinland pfals zu den Aussichten
gleich mehr von östen terli um 21:45 Uhr
gibt das heutejournal mit Christian
Siebers das war's von uns schönen Dank
und bis
[Musik]
morgen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter einiges an Schnee
war heute dabei und das ist diesem Tief
hier zu verdanken was in der Nacht im
Nordwesten lag und uns erreicht hat im
Tagesverlauf und etwa
jetzt in der Mitte liegt und weiter nach
Südosten ziehen wird es wird abziehen
und dahinter wird es auflockern in der
Nacht Schneid es aber weiter vor allem
in der Mitte bis in tiefe Lagen hier
natürlich Glätte dabei im Süden mischt
sich regen dazu ganz im Nordwesten da
lockert es auch von Norden her wird es
allmählich ruhiger und die Temperaturen
-3° im Nordosten und 5° im Südwesten
hier also etwas milder morgen dann
Schneefälle in der Mitte das wandt
allmählich südwärts im Süden ist Regen
dabei ansonsten Sonnenschein Richtung
Ostsee ebenfalls Schneeflocken und die
Temperaturen steigen nur auf -1 bis 0°
in der Mitte und nach ostenin also hier
Dauerfrost eisig kalt 6° im Südwesten
deutlich milder die nächsten Tage
weiterer Schnee und Regen folgt vor
allem nach Nordosten deutlich kühler als
im Südwesten -2 bis 5° am Mittwoch und
damit einen schönen Abend